[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire je reçois aujourd'hui
l'écrivain jean-christophe grangé pour
son beau livre tokyo pourpre illustré
par des photos de patrick shibo ni un
voyage dans le tokyo honda grande dans
lequel il va nous guider en connaisseur
la violoncelliste héloïse luzzati pour
la boîte à pépite un calendrier de
l'avent musicale qu'elle a réalisé avec
son association elle women composeur qui
met en avant des femmes compositrices de
musique classique une par jour du 1er au
24 décembre et julien gélase pour sa
pièce le jeu du président qui se joue au
théâtre du chêne noir avignon une satire
du pouvoir face aux mouvements des
filets jaunes et l'on commence tout de
suite par les images que vous avez
choisie pour illustrer notre époque mais
la vôtre julien pour commencer
c'est ça c'est notre époque
c'est parce il faudrait commenter mais
oui cc il se trouve que j'ai pensé quand
vous m'avez demandé ça j'ai pensé à une
petite anecdote que j'ai vécu sur un
marché de provence où je faisais mes
courses où un jeune homme ne me dis
jamais payé il me dit vous faites le
sans contact et j'ai même pas eu le
temps de nous répondre oui qui me dit
c'est déjà mais c'est pas votre corps
votre époque mais ils me chambrent comme
ça on avait à peine cinq ans dix ans
d'écart 1 et il devait avoir 20 ans et
là ça m'a choqué c'est un bleu au moment
du coc vide du début du co lead et donc
j'ai pensé à c'est en effet parce que je
pense qu'on est dans une époque où les
rapports sont de plus en plus distant il
ya des contrepoints mais c'est vrai que
voilà le contact est pas vraiment la
moto
votre image avoué le lisent
ces jeux des films ouais
ça parle pareil ça parle tout seul
pourquoi pourquoi cette image tout
simplement outre le coup de
communication du gouvernement c'est
quand même un symbole très fort et puis
un une petite vague d'espoir qu'elle
emmène dans son sillage
bas toutes ces artistes ignoré par
l'histoire et un vent de reconnaissance
elle n'avait pas été histoire
c'est la première connaît pas c'est la
première star noire de l'industrie
musicale internationale en plus c'est de
là de voir une sixième femme artiste
entrée au panthéon je vois la c1 c'est
mon petit espoir voilà en ayant choisi
cette photo de me dire que ça peut
générer voilà une vague de
reconnaissances et vous jean christophe
grangé votre image et vous c'est celle
ci en qu'est ce que c'est
ça c'est la bagarre hier de là
j'ai choisi ça parce que faut parer
rendre ces choses là mais moi ça m'a
fait vraiment beaucoup rire pourquoi ça
m'a fait penser au village d'astérix
quoi le moindre beatty mais là on voit
pas les chaises qui volent mais c'est
vraiment
le meeting des rives de la mythique
d'eric zemmour c'est fini avec des
chaises qui volettent les des clés
et j'ai trouvé ça très drôle mais bon
parieur faut parer à ces sérieuses et la
politique mais j'ai trouvé pas même les
français encore la pêche de comme de
petits villages et le poissonnier
avec le fort et bien comment chaud
[Musique]
jean christophe grangé vous êtes
l'auteur du vol des cigognes de l'empiré
des loups et bien sûr des rivières
pourpres le roman qui vous a rendu
célèbre aujourd'hui vous publiez tokyo
pourpre chez albin michel un beau livre
illustré par des photos de patrick
siboni un livre à la gloire du japon en
général de tokyo en particulier le japon
écrivez-vous est un pays où la vulgarité
n'existe pas à ce point oui mais je
crois qu'on peut dire ça c'est un pays
pour les gens qui aiment l'esthétisme le
raffinement et la non vulgarité c'est un
pays parfait c'est un pays où tout le
monde est chic où tout le monde est en
retrait de lésions des étrangers ça
parce que peut-être que les japonais
vulgarité voir des photos qui vont
tout de même il ya une ligne de conduite
de d'habillement de maintien qui est
quand même très très rigoureuse et qui
est naturel chez eux et qui est très
très agréable quand on est là bas c'est
génial mousse qu'ils respirent au japon
c'est la femme vous le dites c'est clair
d'ailleurs votre femme
et ma femme est japonaise donc par mes
reportages quand j'étais journaliste
j'avais déjà pas mal voyager au japon
puis ayant rencontré ma femme je me suis
remis au japon j'ai une grande passion
pour le japon j'ai appris la langue
maintenant j'y vais vraiment très
souvent avant le coc vide
personne ni ben non c'est un pays qui
m'apaise qui me fait beaucoup de bien et
qui est qui a énormément de qualités
qu'ont disparu en france donc ça me fait
beau ça me fait du bien quelles qualités
pour c'est vous la propreté déjà le
courage de travailler là c'est
la politesse
l'application des gens quand il ya un
problème les gens sont là ils disent bon
win ma société à a commis une erreur je
suis là j'assume mes responsabilités
s'est jamais de la faute de personne et
voilà moi je suis très très amoureux de
ce pays qu'il ya des vraies valeurs qui
me parle c'est des valeurs qui font que
la société marche bien et moi étant un
vrai français c'est-à-dire travers sans
toujours ce verre etc sous l'influencé
de la population japonaise vous les
disciplines et vous devenez japonais
c'est très agréable moi je passe un mois
la base un mois sans énervement sans
engueulades dans la circulation sont
c'est très reposant alors vous dites que
c'est une société sous pression la
société japonaise dont la soupape doit
s'entrouvrir
régulièrement d'où les différences entre
tokyo jour tokyo la nuit oui alors là
j'ai fait un portrait paradisiaque de
tokyo il faut mettre le bémol tout de
même du travail où là il ya un petit
excès quand même les gens qui
travaillent énormément énormément tout
le temps tout le temps tout le temps et
c'est quand même une société sous
pression sous un couvercle personne n'a
le droit de rien dire c'est une forme de
dictature un petit peu si vous voulez
est alors en effet là quand vient la
nuit les gens des compresses et ça donne
une nuit qui est égale au jour aussi
active aussi animé est totalement
délirante donc voulu être sur célé
dictature de la collectivité vous faut
une dictature collectif qui fait que
tout le monde file droit disons qu'il
m'était le droit voilà alors il faut
bien voir pour ceux qui ne sont jamais
allés à tokyo c'est une ville
gigantesque
1,14 million d'habitants
160000 restaurant s'est vu la lune
chiffrés dans et dans votre livre est
pas de numéros sur les façades
c'est vrai que c'est couvert tokyo
vraiment en profondeur aujourd'hui donc
avec google maps etc je sais pas comment
les gens faisait avant parce qu'il n'y a
pas de numéro donc on se repère à telle
boutique mais si par malheur la boutique
a disparu entretemps bah voilà et donc
d'en lancer un labyrinthe et pourtant
ils reçoivent leur courrier donc quand
vous êtes du quartier vous connaissez
très bien les rues les coins les mets
mais encore une fois si une idée un peu
fausse parce que le
on a l'idée d'un tokyo qui est une
fourmilière c'est vrai qu'il ya
énormément de monde mais en même temps
il ya énormément de quartier
complètement désert d'immenses parcs moi
je circule à vélo là bas je traverse
très souvent des quartiers totalement
désert c'est une ville très apaisante on
on a cette idée de l'image pressurer etc
et pour un étranger parce qu'encore une
fois les japonais travaillent trop et
c'est vrai que sont sous pression pour
un étranger c'est une ville qui qui qui
n'offrent que des qualités que c'est
tokyo le 19 juin non j'ai vécu à un rat
chinois à pékin mais trois ans mais je
connais pas de toit du tout pareil
je n'oserais pas les comparaisons on
voit des beaucoup de restaurants dans
ces photos j'ai dit vous on comptait 160
milles
on commence à être très connaisseur des
sushi shop en france il faut bien dire
que ça n'a rien à voir avec les sushis
qu'on mange à tokyo à non non moi quand
je mange des sushis à paris j'ai le
cafard
non ça n'a rien à voir il faut dire
aussi que les sushis c'est une infime
partie de la la nourriture japonaise ils
ont une variété de gastronomie
incroyable incroyable à la barre ont
choisi par un restaurant on choisit une
spécialité le soir hier il y en a
tellement c'est lional énormément et ça
aussi c'est une fausse idée on a
l'impression que les japonaises sont
travailleurs un peu sacrifié un peu
austère pas du tout c'est d'être très
très bon vivant et alors ils sont
fanatiques de la nourriture fanatiques
fanatiques de la pâtisserie c'est pour
ça qu'il ya énormément de marques
françaises là bas et il ya aussi
beaucoup de restaurants étrangers oui il
ya tout il ya toutes les spécialités
japonaises plus toutes les spécialités
des autres pays pourquoi est ce que la
télé japonaise diffuse en été des films
d'horreur ça c'est un projet très
intéressant et les japonais sont très
soucieux de la température du corps et
croit énormément à des phénomènes
influences qui pourrait baisser notre
température donc on est et on met des
films d'horreur qui glace le sang ils
sont censés nous refroidir c'est assez
étrange mais c'est vrai c'est une
tradition j'ai beaucoup de films
d'horreur on était la nature est très
présente dans la culture japonaise oui
beaucoup plus que dans la nôtre bien sûr
d'abord parce que ces religieux il le
shintô isme qui est une religion qui
consiste à penser qu'il ya des esprits
un peu partout et notamment dans les
arbres notamment dans l'est dans les
rivières est partout et encore une fois
aussi à tokyo il ya énormément de nature
énormément de parcs énormément d'arbres
et vous sentez toujours la nature qui
est là et qui a une importance
essentielle fondamentale c'est pas du
tout décoratifs au japon la nature et il
ya beaucoup de bohème on croit toujours
que les gens bossent énormément que ce
tous sont tous des salarymen et des
offices gold comme on les appelle en
comme les appelait les américains est en
réalité dans derrien et yorda évidemment
il y en a beaucoup mais il ya aussi des
artistes il ya toute une bohème à tokyo
alors moi comme je parle de la nuit à
tokyo évidemment je parle beaucoup de de
la bohème de tous les artistes
énormément d'artistes dans tous les
domaines et évidemment leur univers
c'est que tout de même la nuit donc dans
les bars dans les clubs il ya énormément
de théâtre vous rencontrer des artistes
des artistes des artistes et le monde de
la nuit est bon accueil évidemment le
monde du jour tous les tous les salariés
qui viennent boire des coups etc mais
c'est quand même un monde à part quand
vous quand vous avez appartenu au monde
de la nuit c'est très difficile de
revenir au monde du jour par exemple ces
demoiselles elles ont peu de chance de
devenir office les 10
son parti serait ce qui est fascinant
quand on arrive à tokyo et qu'on va dans
les quartiers à la mode ce sont toutes
ces ces jeunes beaucoup plus jeune
qu'elle déguisés comme ça mais dans la
jourée béquille je vais en ange
peroxydée posture et la pression que
tokyo c'était le paradis des coiffeurs
c'est ce que je dis dans mon livre c'est
surtout le paradis delà de la
contradiction c'est à dire il ya tous
les excès dont et tous les contraires
qui cohabitent et comment dirais-je on
voit ses excès vestimentaires mais en
même temps c'est un c on voit énormément
des milliards d'hommes en costumes des
milliards de femmes en tailleur c'est
tout ça cohabitent ensemble c'est
vraiment passionnante mais voilà bon là
c'est oui mais là il faut faire dans mon
livre on avance dans la nuit et plus on
avance dans la nuit plus on devient un
peu interdits aux moins de 18 ans quand
même dit que les tous les clubs dont
rêvent les dj sont à tokyo la wii que
tôt que c'est le paradis de l'électro ah
oui ça c'est moi j'ai découvert la barre
un monde encore garnis bon alors si vous
voulez quand vous êtes étrangers dans un
pays vous vous sentez tout permis donc
moi je vais malgré mon grand âge dans
les clubs et je suis totalement
émerveillé de ces clubs absolument dans
un noir total avec une sono qui fait
vibrer le sol les murs et ça j'aurais pu
le faire en france donc je connais bien
le monde des dj de l'électro à tokyo et
à une qualité d'abord il invite tous les
grandes stars de toute la planète et
puis il invite aussi les types en dehors
g très peu connu alors ça commence à 3
heures du matin dans le noir total c'est
vraiment grisant c'est vraiment une
autre planète c'est ce que j'ai essayé
de montrer dans le vivant voilà vous
revoir en plus les des gens qui adorent
se déguiser alors par exemple halloween
c'est un moment extraordinaire à tokyo
est alors dans ces soirées là qui sont
des soirées fétiche on a des sacrés
déguisements je peux vous dire merci
vous aviez comme ça vous sentez un peu
les adolescents japonais sortent pour
permanence déguisé dans la ruche aller
oui j'ai derrière qu'ils ont toute une
période jusqu'à la fin du lycée en
costumes tous nous les les écoliers et
lycéens sont en costume au japon ensuite
quand il commence à bosser ils sont deux
nouveaux costumes et il ya si vous
voulez une plage où là on peut faire
n'importe quoi il s'en prive pas et ses
chevaux le week end et le week end je
couds tout ça il ya tout le monde qui
vient se déguiser et alors vous le
décrivez comme le pays de la pudeur de
la discrétion du respect et comment ils
font pour se reproduire
à 16 face un vaste débat si vous voulez
en d'abord ils ont un problème de
reproduction ça se le dise pour une son
caca plein de raisons sociologiques mais
je pense que c'est d'abord une raison de
traditionnels quand vous commencez à
faire des enfants un enfant déjà ça
coûte très cher d'avoir un enfant au
japon les écoles tout est payant donc
les gens font des vraiment des enfants
au compte gouttes et puis on dit que la
libido a disparu alors comme vous pouvez
voir
[Rires]
la libido quand même bien survécu à
tokyo mais c'est vrai que quand même
avec le travail harassant avec cette
séparation des rôles très strictes au
japon où la femme quand elle devient
mère elle devient vraiment femme au
foyer devient une espèce de madone qu'on
doit plus touchés et l'homme alors
arrive sur les rotules à 23h bon oui on
peut on peut dire quand même comme d'une
façon générale activité sexuelle chez
les gens disons ordinaire et payet est
pas très très très exacerbée en revanche
dans le tokyo que je décris c'est à dire
le tokyo de la nuit le tokyo qui offre
qui offre toute la réalisation des
fantasmes lala cet actif là vous
raconter des deux très amusante vous
dites qu à chaque fois vous étiez invité
à dîner chez des japonais on vous avait
dit qu'il travaillait comme des dingues
jusqu'à 23 ans le soir il était toujours
étonné qu'ils vous invitent à 18 heures
chez eux oui mais celle ci est en fait
vous avez eu la réponse est c'est à dire
que une personne durant la semaine dans
sa société par à 18 heures pour dîner
avec des amis pendant ce temps là tous
les autres travaillent jusqu'à lundi le
lendemain c'est un autre il décide de
sortir c'est à partir de 18h et ça se
finit pas 21h on peut sortir
la fête dans le sang mais encore une
fois c'est très cadré trois de ses
cadres à l heure on l'a compris la
nudité est proscrite au japon mais le
japon c'est quand même un très gros
producteur de porno alors voilà encore
une contradiction tout est
compartimentée au japon donc dans dix on
l'a par exemple à la télévision grand
public dans les publicités alors là vous
verrez même pas un dos même pas un coup
de c'est vraiment proscrit par contre si
vous revoyez la petite porte du porno
alors là
le pays du port mais à une époque on
foutait les sexes ça n'est plus le cas
c'est toujours assez toujours un
fragment de loi qui traîne donc il ya
une mosaïque toujours sur les sexes soit
mais si vous voulez du point de vue de
la production d'abord c'est des milliers
et des milliers de films par an qu'est
ce que je dis oui des dizaines de
milliers de films par an et puis bon
disons le sujet des films est très très
variés c'est les japonais ont inventé le
porno sur commande c'est à dire ils ont
déniché savent que tel public aime fatem
suis maintenant tous les sites pornos
occidentaux reposent ces petites niches
et c'est eux qui ont inventé regardez la
femme dans l'aquarium ça me fait penser
oui le port du chapeau n'est non plus
si on inverse le rôle de l'homme et de
la femme dans la photo déjà peut-être
peut-être
mais dans l'érotisme japonais et les as
raison c'est là aussi une division du
travail très net 1 c'est plus souvent la
femme attachée comme attaché
willaya natale même attaché mais on
imagine ce n'est pas une femme qui l'a
attaché à cet or est à la fois d'eric je
saute sur l'occasion pour expliquer que
tout ce qu'on peut voir dans le livre
qui parfois peuvent choquer parce que
donne une image de la femme soumise où
il ya beaucoup de shibari le shibari
c'est le bondage d'entre elles les
femmes attachées sur si ce n'est dans
tous les sens il faut quand même savoir
que les femmes sont volontaires c'est
pour leur plaisir n'a absolument pas de
comment dire personne n'est payé
personne fait ça pour personne ne
souffre pour de l'argent c'est souffrir
pour le plaisir donc ça c'est comme si
vous appliquez meilleurs jeux cultes du
bondage au japon nous n'avons survivance
de l'impérialisme de là c'est presque
des kamikazes et ils ont inventé la
corde était très importante à l'époque
d'abord la corde est importante parce
que c'est ce qui marque la présence d
esprit quand vous avez un arbre entouré
d'une corde c'est à dire qu'il ya un
esprit dans cet arbre alors après il ya
eu la tradition des samouraïs qui
attaché leur leurs prisonniers avec un
soin tout à fait particulier selon la
faute que vous aviez fait vous étiez
ligoté d'une façon différente tout ça
s'est un peu perdue après avec l'armée
fille tout ça et là effet il faut bien
reconnaître il ya certes un homme
certaines femmes qui ont découvert que
ça les amuse est de s'attacher de se
faire attacher il y prenait du plaisir
donc ce n' est du japon mais aujourd'hui
bon il ya pas mal de photos de bondage
dans mon livre mais c'est pas non plus
comment dirais-je faut pas croire que
tous les japonais après le film de la
télé sa tâche
un groupuscule des petits clubs traître
ou carrier vous parliez de l'ère meiji
c'est à partir de ces terres là que le
japon s'ouvre à l'occident jusqu'à
présent les occidentaux ont été
interdits au japon il est il nous
laisser rentrer à peine pour faire du
commerce et la plupart du temps ils nous
ont viré il voulait surtout pas être
contaminé par nous et l'affluence
américaine quand même elle est
considérable au japon aujourd'hui ils
ont été occupées pendant 15 ans oui
alors aujourd'hui je ne saurais pas dire
si c'est une influence comme on dirige
un modèle encore ou au contraire une
allergie ou une indépendance je pense
qu'ils sont passés par évidemment il ya
beaucoup de choses qui rappellent les
étasuniens mais je pense qu'ils ont
gagné vraiment leur indépendance
aujourd'hui 10 aime bien la france moi
j'aime bien aussi le japon parce que
quand vous êtes français et vous vous
revendre est-ce qu'ils aient une
influence du japon dans vos romans gens
que j'ai écrit un roman qui parlait un
peu de mes débuts en tant qu'époux d'une
japonaise avec tous mes questionnements
et médéa roi donc sage écrit un livre
là-dessus mais sinon non pas vraiment
moi je suis surtout influencé par le
cinéma japonaises j'adore le cinéma
japonaises surtout celui des années 50
60 70 génération oui mais qu'elle est un
cinéma merveilleux beaucoup plus active
de bauchi
extraordinaire extraordinaire puis après
il m'a mourra tout ça c'est vraiment
d'écran grand cinéaste mais dans mes
livres
n'ont peut-être tout certaines un sens
de l'héroïsme chez mes flic qui sont un
peu samouraï un peu solitaire un peu
dévoué totalement à leur enquête ça ça
c'est une idée qui me plaît et ça c'est
typiquement japonais pour vous ah oui
ils ont poussé l'héroïsme et puis là le
sens du devoir le sens du dévouement à
un degré ont massé très connu les
kamikazes et tout ça
cd c'est tout de même un peuple à un
moment donné si lol le collectif a
décidé quelque chose il ya plus à
discuter même s'il s'agit d'alexandre
plafonné dans un avion il ya plus à
discuter c'est ils n'y allaient pas du
tout de gaieté de coeur un faut pas
croire que les japonais adorent la mort
mais il fallait y aller c'était c'est le
collectif avait décidé c'est un peuple
c'est vraiment on a perdu totalement la
notion de peuple en france le là-bas le
ski doit marcher c'est le peuple donc là
l'individualité passe toujours bien
après tokyo pourpre ça vient de paraître
aux éditions albin michel
[Musique]
héloïse lucrative ou est violoncelliste
et avec votre association elle créative
woman vous voulez faire connaître les
femmes qui ont composé de la musique
classique qui sont bien plus nombreuses
qu'on ne le croit pour y contribuer vous
avez réalisé un calendrier de l'avent
musicale la boîte à pépites que l'on
peut voir sur youtube et sur facebook
chaque jour du 1er au 24 décembre
apparaît une compositrice on va regarder
tout de suite celle du 4 décembre où
d'ailleurs vous apparaissez parce qu'il
n'est pas dans chaque évidemment on vous
regarde
[Musique]
je m'appelle chikhi ni à gonzaga je suis
né à rio de janeiro en 1847 j'ai été
formé par les meilleurs professeurs de
la capitale
l'année de mes 16 ans mon père un
militaire de famille noble marange un
mariage avec un officier de la marine
marchande avec qui j'aurai trois enfants
mon mari détestait la musique et même un
jour demandé de choisir entre lui et
elle ce à quoi je lui répondis eh bien
monsieur mon mari je ne comprends pas la
vie sans harmonie à la recherche de
l'harmonie qui n'était manifestement pas
chez moi et bien plus dans la musique je
le quittais perdant ainsi la garde de
mes enfants pour survivre je donnais des
cours et jouer du piano dans des bars
avant de rencontrer un autre homme
d'accoucher d'une autre fille et que
l'histoire se répète à nouveau
j'ai contribué à créer un langage
musical typiquement brésilien est
composé l'hymne du carnaval une de mes
opérette à enchaîner 1500 représentation
on peut dire que mes choix familiaux et
professionnels m'ont été extrêmement
préjudiciable socialement mais d'un
autre côté ma liberté de penser d'écrire
et de vivre à libérer la place des
femmes dans la musique brésilienne en
devenant l'une des premières femmes
chefs d'orchestre au monde reconnu pour
mon talent et mes compositions
[Musique]
m
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ans
alors d'abord j'ai fait une boulette
c'est elles composent eux-mêmes non
seulement de composants c'est le nom de
votre association qui a eu cette
excellente idée puisque on n'arrête pas
de découvrir des compositrices qu'on ne
connaissez pas c'est le cas de cette
brésilienne
c'est comment ça vous est venue l'idée
du calendrier de l'avent oui le
calendrier de l'avent bien sûr
alors
il ya un avant le calendrier de l'avent
c'est la naissance du projet de cette
association qui est vraiment d'aller
rendre plus d'oeuvres de compositrice
visible c'est à dire qu'on est un petit
groupe de musiciens on récupère des
manuscrits on les lit et on se dit
qu'est ce qu'on en fait c'est bien c'est
pas bien l'idée c'est pas de remède
et des partitions cd partitions mais des
partitions qui ne sont plus ou pas
forcément édités qui n'ont été parfois
des premières éditions qu'on retrouve à
la bibliothèque nationale de france ou
dans d'autres bibliothèques à l'étranger
on fait notre petite chasse au trésor et
puis on se retrouve pour lire la musique
parce que beaucoup d'hommes ne sont pas
encore enregistrées pour la plupart
d'ailleurs il ya énormément de données
enregistrées et puis à partir de là on
se dit qu'est ce qu'on en fait c'était
pas bien on n'en fera rien parce que
l'idée sympa de jouer des oeuvres juste
parce qu'une famille à composer mais
juste parce qu'elles ont été évincés de
l'histoire de la musique parce que
composé par une femme donc du coup si on
est convaincu que cette oeuvre mérite
d'être joué on réfléchit à comment la
mettre en valeur et ce calendrier on est
une des manières c'est à dire de créer
un projet qui soit très accessible pour
tout le monde même des gens qui sont pas
forcément très mélomane ont fait une
pause et on y revient juste après
[Musique]
nous sommes toujours avec jean
christophe grangé avec julien g là c'est
avec héloïse that i qui est
violoncelliste et qui nous est en train
de nous parler de ce calendrier de
l'avent musicale qui est disponible donc
sur youtube et sur facebook une
compositrice que l'on découvre chaque
jour du 1er au 24 décembre
le calendrier de l'avent vous ne l'avez
dit c'est une manière de rendre de les
rendre visibles pour le plus grand
nombre et pas seulement pour ceux qui
sont passionnés par la musique classique
sachant que ni les uns ni les autres ne
les connaissent elles ont disparu de
l'histoire c'est ces composites et
jouets qu'on a on écoute tout de suite
celle du 2 décembre elle s'appelle gayan
et chez boat ariane je la connaissais
pas du tout j'ai adoré tout de suite ce
prélude qu'on va entendre on peut le
trouver je les trouvais depuis vécu à
acheter voilà c'est pas le cas pour
toutes mais celui dont on peut le
trouver on écoute un extrait
[Musique]
je m'appelle gaillanais chez hbo ariane
je suis né en 1918 à rostov dindane ou
au sud de la russie
j'ai fait mes études au conservatoire de
leningrad avant d'enseigner au
conservatoire de yerevan où j'ai créé un
cours dédié à la musique polyphonique
arménienne j'ai d'ailleurs écrit un
livre sur la polyphonie dans les oeuvres
de khatchaturian avant d'être nommé
professeur de composition en 1965 je
suis distinguer artistes honorés par la
rss d'arménie les compositions sont
inspirés par les mélodies
traditionnelles arméniennes les
également par la musique russe le piano
est omniprésent dans mon oeuvre est
souvent une certaine mélancolie se
dégage de mes compositions comme dans
ceux préludes pour piano
[Musique]
e
m
[Musique]
e
on
nous
e
[Musique]
oh
héloïse that i vous dites que seulement
1% des compositeurs de musique classique
qui sont joués aujourd'hui en france
sont des femmes 4 4%
effectivement c'est le domaine
artistique le plus en retrait rend quand
il s'agit d'égalité effectivement
aujourd'hui la ligne à 4 % des oeuvres
qui sont programmés dans l'est dans les
établissements qui sont composées par
des femmes c'est très peu et c'est pas
représentatif de la réalité c'est
surtout ça s'ils s'étaient aperçus vous
un moment que j'avais 25 ans on faisait
du violoncelle vous aviez jamais joué
une partition écrite par une femme moi
c'est ça si je me suis dit qu'il y avait
quand même une baleine sous le caillou
et quand vous m'avez quand même pas tout
raconté et qu'il y avait un truc dans
l'éducation dans notre éducation
musicale qui est qu'ils n'allaient pas
alors je pense que c'est des choses qui
vont changer je pense que les
générations suivantes ce sera différente
mon fils à 7 ans il remarque dans sa
méthode de piano il n'y a pas de
compositrice et que c'est quand même
bizarre mais justement alors quelle est
l'explication parce qu'ils existent vous
les trouvez là chaque jour on en
découvre une nouvelle qu'on ne
connaissait pas donc vous avez fait les
recherches elles sont pas éditer donc
c'était un vrai boulot d'aller les
chercher un
voilà qu'est ce qui leur est arrivé
alors je vais vous donner un exemple
parce que qui représentatif de beaucoup
et puis chacune a son histoire il ya des
fois des histoires aussi de l'histoire
c'est à dire quand on a une beaucoup de
reconnaissance avant la seconde guerre
mondiale et qu'après la seconde la vie
avait tellement changé enfin voila il
peut y avoir aussi où divers thèmes
l'argent elle était juive elle a été
déportée
elle surtout après la guerre elle a pas
retrouvés elle a dû se cacher et puis
elle n'a pas retrouvé voilà la place
dans le mais ce n'est pas la seule il y
en a beaucoup mais c'était pareil pour
les hommes donc là on peut pas gérer
cette partie là mais par contre je vais
vous donner un exemple que je trouve
assez représentatif de beaucoup de
compositrice c'est louise farrenc une
compositrice française parmi les plus
connus réussir les bonnes chirurgie mais
voilà mais ça fait partie des
compositrices quand on connaît quelques
compositrice qui peuvent voilà venir
dans la liste de noms elle quelques
années avant sa mort on lui prédit dans
le dictionnaire universel universel
pardon un immense à venir dans
l'histoire de la musique et quelques
années après son décès dans ce même
dictionnaire c'est écrit professeur au
conservatoire de paris il n'ya plus le
mot compain compositrice ne l'utilisé
pas mais le mot compositeur a disparu
c'est à dire que en cinq ans quand une
compositrice n'est plus là pour faire
perdurer son oeuvre pour la faire vivre
et bien en fait le dans l'histoire
l'histoire de la musique a été écrite
globalement presque uniquement par des
hommes et elle a effacé les femmes de
l'histoire de la musique et parfois
certaines femmes ont eu beaucoup de
succès ont été très joué l'éditer c'est
juste que c'est pas rester un dernier
extrait les allemann
extrême
[Musique]
je m'appelle lisa lehman je suis né à
londres en 1862 d'une mère chanteuse et
d'un père artiste peintre j'ai d'abord
vécu en italie avant de m'établir à
londres avec mes trois soeurs ma mère a
été mon premier professeur est très
jeune je me suis tourné vers la
composition
j'ai également suivi des cours à rome et
à wiesbaden ce qui m'a permis de parler
couramment l'anglais l'allemand et
l'italien ma carrière de soprano débute
à londres mais je me produis également
en france et en allemagne avec les plus
grands musiciens de mon époque dont
youssef yoakim et clara schumann
parallèlement à ma carrière de
concertiste je publie mes propres
compositions
après mon mariage je renonce pour un
temps à ma carrière de soprano mais
continue à composer j'aime écrire pour
la voix un de mes plus grands succès
arrivera avec le cycle dans un jardin
persan j'ai fait plusieurs tournées en
amérique composé plus de 200 mélodies
des pièces pour piano et violon et des
opéras j'ai enseigné à la guildhall
school of music et j'ai été la première
président de la société des femmes
musiciennes
[Musique]
ça par exemple ou ne trouvent pas en
disque et c'est quand même incroyable
étant donné le nombre de doses qu'on
peut trouver en disque 5 min s'est
véritablement parce que c'est une femme
parce que c'est très joli ce qu'on
entend là et s'était dit et et j'ai
trouvé la partition sur im/s lp qu'est
quand même la grosse banque de
partitions aligne donc qui veut chanter
ce cycle peut se connecter trouve la
partition comme ça et effectivement j'ai
même pas eu à chercher la partition
juste prix la partition jeu les
déchiffrer du système super beau et en
fait ça ça arrive tout le temps l'appart
la mélodie qui sera donné ce soir c'est
pareil à la l'a jamais été enregistrés
même puisse même pas si ça a été jouée
depuis la mort de la compositrice tci
même pas sûr je pense pas donc si on
veut participer ou du moins être
recevoir ce qu'elles ont veillé de
l'avancé sur youtube et sur facebook le
mieux c'est la boîte à musique la voie
est la pépite pardon la boîte à pépites
et on les trouve tout de suite merci
héloïse du zèle si vous
[Musique]
julien gélase votre pièce le jeu du
président se joue à partir du 9 décembre
au théâtre du chêne noir avignon dans
une mise en scène de votre père gérard
gélas ce la politique est un jeu dit au
président de la république son
conseiller le plus proche il est vital
pour vous de le penser comme ça sinon
vous ne tiendrez pas plus d'un mandat
qu'est ce qu'il entend par là où qu'est
ce que vous vous entendez par là la
politique est un jeu ça veut dire que la
politique est une comédie ça veut dire
que la politique est une plaisanterie ou
au contact c'est très sérieux que c'est
dangereux et plein d'incertitudes comme
le jeu justement mais je pense que c'est
un peu tout ça personnellement j'ai là
le personnage en l'occurrence c'est le
cousin spes de conseiller occulte du
président qui va d'emblée au début de la
pièce le mettre en garde sur les dangers
qui peut y avoir à prendre au sérieux
tout ce qui arrive aux peaux avenant
comme ça et donc il va lui lancer un
défi en lui disant amusez-vous moi je
vais être là pour cela je vais de là
pour vous pour vous allégez pour vous
mettre un petit peu de
ludique dans votre dans votre parcours
sauf que c'est une vision cynique du
pouvoir évidemment à partir du moment où
on a une vision on prend les choses à la
légère alors même qu'on joue avec la vie
des gens
ça peut entraîner certaines
problématiques donc il ya en effet après
le jeu du président c'est une c'est à la
fois le jeu la stratégie et en même
temps la comédie aussi je me semble que
le pouvoir est toujours dans ses
extrêmes ridicule donc oui oui je pense
qu'il ya qui a dans le il ya toujours un
côté ridicule et en fait ce qui s'est
passé depuis le début du quinquennat
actuel puisque
ma grande source d'inspiration vient de
ce quinquennat c'est pas une pièce à
charge le 10 mai c'est du spectaculaire
permanent des erreurs des contradictions
permanentes et donc c'est si on prend un
peu de recul c'est assez comique s'est
décalé c'est je vais dire ce qu'on nous
a fait par exemple c'est comme tout le
monde avec les masques par exemple
sur le moment on rit pas mais avec un
peu de recul on se dit quand même c'est
assez c'est vous mieux en rire mais
quand on quand on voit votre pièce sont
audibles c'est un peu l'elysée
a peu vu paris gilet jaune quand même
c'est à dire comme si l'elysée était un
mélange de maternelle de pénitencier et
de boxon disons que c'est l'elysée
une pièce qui s'inscrit dans une
tradition de théâtral qui n'est pas
nouvelle qui est de parler du roi en
place il se trouve que je me désole
souvent faim de bien moins que on parle
souvent des rois qui ont précédé ou des
présidents qui l'ont précédé
là c'est pas une pièce sur emmanuel
macron je le dis mais l inspiration on
vient c'est pas la nuit ça se passe
pendant tous les événements qu'a
traversé emmanuel macron exactement soit
le gilet jaune ou ensuite la pandémie de
covin exactement ce sont les toiles de
fond voilà mais je veux dire les
révolutions les tensions de la foule qui
sont ces dans l'histoire depuis depuis
toujours donc il n'y a rien de nouveau à
ça il se trouve que de là on avait quand
même un événement deux ans qui as
extraordinaire où comme le président a
du sphinx filtrer un hélicoptère et
étaient prêts à aller se réfugier dans
le bunker le pc jupiter pour ne pas être
presque passer le fil du rasoir il avait
prévu tout ça donc c'est quand même
assez il l'avait prévu c'est au moment
au plus fort de la révolte et gilet
jaune quand et gilles et jo tu voulais
venir jusqu'à l'elysée il avait prévu à
2 il n'y avait pas deux maps à une
panique disons que lui il n'était pas en
grande forme à ce moment là
en tout cas et c'était il ya une énorme
tension et selon ces témoignages en tout
cas de gaulle n'était pas en grande
forme pendant mai 68 non plus exact
exact donc c'est pas un effet de nouveau
mais là c'est vrai que c'était inspirant
mais alors justement c'est à la fois
emmanuel macron sans être emmanuel
macron mai mais enfin c'est emmanuel
macron puisque tout ce qui passe cette
arrivée à emmanuel macron même si par
ailleurs il ya une intrigue plus
personnel qui n'a rien à voir avec
emmanuel macron bien entendu mais
pourquoi vous lui fait de dire vous fait
réciter des citations de sarkozy ou de
hollande et on ne sait très bien que
sont des citations de sarkozy hollande
parce que c'est parmi les plus célèbres
à la fois le mois président de de
hollande où je suis une ferrari c'est
sarkozy qui disait ça il faut pour
ouvrir le capot faut mettre des gants
préfère dire à emmanuel macron il en ait
dit suffisamment ont pu lui faire ses
propres citation exacte il y en a au
début puisque le prêt le conseiller
convoi l'a incarnée par didier brice en
fait lui passe en revue toutes les
fameuses déclarations qui ont choqué il
lui dit mais vous avez bien fait de dire
ça de dire parler directement aux
français vous adresser directement
français ça a pu choquer certains des
phrases traverser la rue et vous avez un
travail de ce genre de phrase mais à la
fin en effet jeu c'est une vision
personnelle aussi j'ai je pense qu'il y
a dans ce président en tout cas celui je
voulais montrer un mélange des trois
précédents et je pense que dans
l'actuelle il y a une certaine
combinaison des trois c'est pas
compliqué le président et le précédent
c'est son c était son front poulain on
peut dire fin où il a été le poulain de
françois hollande sarkozy ont tout le
monde sait que actuellement il ya des
échanges très cordiaux entre eux et des
échanges et le voilà et surtout je pense
qu'il ya une politique qui va plus dans
ce sens là ça c'est pas un scoop non
plus donc c'est surtout le conseiller à
la fin qui imagine en fait le discours
parce que ce conseiller l'aï là il en a
vu passer des présidents et il a un
c'est un moment très onirique où il va
déclamer en fait des grands discours et
on finit par le fameux c'est mon projet
et donc il ya un mélange de tout ça
c'est pas le président mais c'est vrai
qu'il ya des références parce que je
pense qu'il ya dans le président actuel
une certaine combinaison avec l'ombre de
françois mitterrand quand même derrière
voilà deux présidents et jeu par contre
j'ai dû plus de mal à voir justement et
c'est ça qui m'a intéressé d'identité
même du de l'actuel président mais être
président de tous les français est
impossible dit vous sauf en temps de
guerre
c'est pour ça qu'il faut jouer avec le
peuple au fond
alors c'est vrai que c'est la vision
cynique du conseiller il faut dire que
le pitch de départ c'est que ce
conseiller est un conseiller occulte qui
soit disant il est inculte parce que les
clients le modèle de leur envoyer donc
il est officiel tillaoui voilà mais il a
disons dans sa fonction un rapport très
particulier et en vérité son souhait
c'est de faire échouer le président
c'est un homme désespéré et
et donc il va essayer de le mener à sa
perte sauf que le président l'ignorent
il ya autour de ça et donc le fait qu'
on joue éventuellement avec les français
et c'est une vision en fait qui est
celle cynique du conseiller désespérée
c'est pas la mienne je le précise où
c'est peut-être une partie de moi mais
disons qu'il ya il ya une croix aussi
c'est vrai la france est un pays ont
tout à l'heure où sont rangés en parler
un petit peu ou qui est difficilement
gouvernable enfin c'est pas simple et il
c'est vrai que c'est ce qu'il dit au
début il dit la france ne serait pas la
france si elle n'est pas en colère
elle ne serait pas au fond il faut qu'il
ya un moment que ça se soit la
catastrophe pour qu'on soit un moment de
tous unis c'est vrai que tel c'est kalou
japon
j'ai comme l'impression qu'ils haïssent
et un peu
aux antipodes et c'est vrai que voilà
donc au début il était dit le rassure en
lui disant n'hésite pas justement être
politiquement incorrect et parce que au
fond ne sera jamais le président de tous
les français ça commence comme ça
vous avez l'air de reprocher à la
politique et aux politiques en général
de se payer de mots les mots ne sont pas
la réalité c'est ce que vous fait dire à
un de vos personnages
mais comment la percevoir la réalité
sont les mots c'est à dire que si on ne
met pas la réalité ormeaux la réalité
n'existe pas c'est très pertinent et je
crois ce que vous dites et je pense
qu'un des grands malheurs de la
politique et de d'un certain système et
pas que de la politique c'est d'avoir en
effet un filtre permanent devant les
yeux et l'esprit et qui est que au fond
on a on ne perçoit pas ce qui se passe
dans le réel est alors évidemment qu'il
faut le penser le réel et donc il faut
le mettre en mots mais je crois que en
l'occurrence les gens plus coquets l'on
fait référence au nom extrêmement
intelligent très lettré et je pense que
malheureusement des fois ça c'est mon
côté pour le coup un peu asiatiques ou
disons qui va vers le zen justement je
les mots sont aussi des fois peuvent
être des pièges et là on est pétri ce
sont des gens qui font des discours sur
discours qui prépare sans arrêt ce
qu'ils doivent penser et je pense qu'il
ya il ya ça fait un écran absolument
énorme entre le réel qui il se trouve
que le réel dans la nature y'a pas de
mots en dehors de l'humain donc
voilà et c'est vrai que c'est une partie
de la réalité qu'il faut pas négliger la
souffrance là les situations tout ça
après ça se décrypte mais je pense que
d'abord la perception est les premières
dents et elle doit en tout cas c'est
peut-être une vie artistique des choses
mais je trouve que les politiques
devraient dès fois à l'est un peu plus
vers l'art que vers la politique
justement vous votez
qui veulent pas voter jean cazaux jamais
jamais jamais voté jamais du tout du
tout
par principe ou oui j'ai des idées
spéciale je sais pas si c'est le moment
de se développer
mais je suis assez dubitatif sur l'idée
de la démocratie et de demander à tout
le monde son avis comme ça si vous
voulez je considère alors la politique
au sens de la gestion d'un pays la
direction d'un pays je pense que c'est
quelque chose de très compliqué et qu'on
n'est absolument pas en mesure de juger
qui est le meilleur candidat pour pour
ce boulot là vous voyez je pense que
c'est quand même un métier et que ça
demande quand même des compétences des
connaissances que le grand public n'a
pas donc ils vinet et vouloir surtout
pas moi c'est pour ça que je me mets en
retrait imaginez vous arrivé à la gare
de lyon dans les tgv il ya deux
bonhommes près de la cabine du chauffeur
vous devez choisir le chauffeur c'est ça
la dément pas ses impôts il bet vous
pouvez choisir du mort dans quelle
direction elle tgv
devaient choisir le chauffeur peut-être
car d2 a aucune compétence et vous n'en
savez rien et c'est ça la démocratie en
fait on demande aux gens de voter moi
j'ai un souvenir personnel pas grand
mère elle adorait giscard d'estaing
parce qu'il jouait de l'accordéon c'est
ça la démocratie c'est la couleur de la
cravate
heureusement on n'est pas compétent
honnêtement on n'est pas compétent pour
juger de qui peut faire quoi et surtout
pas de juger de la complexité du mois je
suis partisan de laisser le président
gouverner un pays et surtout qu'on lui
foute la paix je veux dire les français
ont quand même le pompon
pour l'ouvrir tous les matins et alors
ce que j'ai particulièrement dans le
collimateur c'est ce qu'on appelle
l'opposition ces terres que quoi que
fasse le président le lendemain matin
ils diront est absolument le contraire
c'est leur vocation leur boulot
c'est pour ça que j'aimais bien le
village d'astérix la
suite je suis très désillusionnés très
en retrait mais alors justement pour est
ce que est ce qu'on peut parler du
pouvoir quand on ne le connaît pas
julien jeunesse parce que la vision que
vous donnez de l'elysée moi par exemple
la une arrive mais après je ne connais
pas plus l'hexagone
je ne sais pas exactement comment ça
fonctionne mais ç'a paru très naïf ou
très cynique aussi un peu influencé par
les séries américaines qui aime bien
montrer des présidents des états unis de
plus en plus dingues de plus en plus
cruelles après ils s'étonnent que des
gens aient pu voter mais fournit avec ce
qu'on leur inflige temps des séries
c'est absolument normal et là je me suis
dit bon c'est un peu voilà c'est
quelqu'un qui ne sait pas comment le
pouvoir fonctionne mais encore une fois
je vous dis je n'en sais pas plus que
vous donc je me dis c'est trop naïf je
ne sais pas comment il faut le pouvoir
fonctionne c'est à dire en effet je ne
vis pas avec ces gens j'ai la chance
enfin la chose s'il me documenter sur
tout ça quand même donc j'ai je me suis
renseigné avant d'écrire cette pièce
après en effet jeu ce n'est pas une
pièce qui est là pour juger je fais pas
mis pour être un miroir de ce qui se
passe à l'elysée d'une envie lui vient
absolument c'est à dire que j'ai pris
des choses qui m'ont inspiré j'en ai
essayé d'en faire une fiction soyons au
clair avec tout ça donc évidemment que
c'est ambigu parce que on se dit on a
l'impression qu'ils aient des références
très réaliste et en même temps on a des
choses qui ne le sont pas forcément
mais au fond ce qui est dans la pièce là
on le retrouve dans les pièces déjà
connue lorenzaccio d'autres tu veux dire
il n'y a rien de
d'extraordinaire au fond à décrire ces
mécanismes là les mécanismes qui sont
des jeux d'influencé de rapports entre
certains conseillers de votre ex terra
des rapports de force ners assez couru
c'est connu donc j'ai essayé de décrire
ça mais surtout de mettre en perspective
un personnage très ambigu très jeudi et
musset je pense à musset qui n'existe
pas qui ce conseiller qui va essayer de
faire échouer le président alors même
que le président croit qu'il est là pour
l'aider et ce conseiller a une fille qui
influencent euse qui est un pseudonyme
sur les réseaux sociaux qui est
extrêmement gauche complètement à
l'extrême gauche et le président va le
faire la faire venir il va y avoir un
pacte entre eux donc c'est voilà la
vision après du pouvoir je ne les je ne
vais pas de l'intérieur ça c'est clair
mais jules abah vous étiez influencé par
les télés réalité il ya un côté love
story weave ils s'étaient tous deux
éliminés mais c'est pas il n'y a pas que
chez vous je ne vois dans à peu près la
moitié des films français aujourd'hui
malheureusement je ne regarde pas de
télé réalité mais peut-être que j'étais
influencé à mon insu par l'idée que l'on
fait un pacte avec intel pour éliminer
intel etc etc c'est gilles c'est comme
ça que j'imaginais la télé réalité que
je sais pas la route car je la connais
pas la réalité je la regarde pas mais
m'est possible c'est possible que ce
soit en tout cas malheureusement c'est
surtout la réalité parce que dans le
pouvoir là en l'occurrence vous êtes
bien renseigné vous connaissez peut-être
mieux que moi ce qui se passe dans la
politique mais une semaine dix trous il
se trouve que c'est ces rapports de
force et s'est mise à mort elles elles
sont elles sont fréquentes en politique
on s'élimine beaucoup je me montre c est
ce qu ont ces limites de cette manière
là mais après tout c'est un parti pris
que vous avez tout à fait le droit de
prendre et encore une fois je vous dis
toute façon l'idée que l'on se fait du
pouvoir et en font la somme des
influences qu'on a reçu beaucoup des
états unis parce qu'il ya beaucoup de
séries je ne regarde pas les séries
américaines dans ce jeu vous étiez plus
de films aux états unis sur la politique
libyen dans ce jeu ne regarde pas les
séries américaines jeunes a pâli série
donc que j'ai peut-être été influencé
par un sable mais sans le savoir
et vous vous avez vous le qui ne votez
pas jean christophe grangé vous
intéressé quand même à la politique ou
même pas non non mariés vous y
intéressez ne pas voter non non non
c'est pas mes affaires d'abord j'ai une
vision très très comment dirais-je
indépendante de la vie c'est à dire je
me suis toujours débrouillé tout seul
depuis que je suis tout petit vous
n'attendez rien de quoi j'attends rien
de et si par malheur quelqu'un me dire
mais c'est égoïste parce que faut penser
aux autres alors là je sors ma feuille
d'impôts
et voilà je pense que le monde mon
équilibre personnel est comme ça mais
certains vous direz mais justement c'est
de tes impôts qu'il s'agit puisque une
fois que vous avez payez vos impôts qui
va répartir l'argent et a quitté les
salles sont les politiques par exemple
l'utilisation des impôts c'est il me
semble et des questions mais très très
complexe moi je suis surpris de voir à
quel point les gens dans les dîners au
café parle de tout ça sans une once de
connaissances dans ce domaine là il
faudrait faire si il faudrait faire ça
enfin il ya le même problème que le
football tout le monde sait toujours ce
qu'il faut faire les amis
il ya donc moi je suis en retrait de ça
et je je commande il ya une chose qui me
frappe dans la démocratie c'est par
exemple je suis pas si c'est française
peut-être dans tous les pays mais il ya
un système de vote par exemple
l'élection du président bon une fois
qu'ils étaient lus moi j'ai vu une manif
un jour élire un président c'est pas
faire un chèque en blanc c'est
précisément faire un chèque en blanc on
a élu quelqu'un bon bah il ya des gens
qui l'ont pas élu mais tant pis pour eux
et puis une fois qu'il est aux commandes
je vois pas pourquoi il ya tant de
commentaires sur le l'oeuvre en cours du
président il a été choisi voter élu
démocratiquement maintenant fermé mais
rien ne l'obligé indiqué même le
programme pour lequel il a été élu alors
regarder un autre que c'est un chèque en
blanc mais c'est un autre problème après
c'est tellement compliqué on reproche
beaucoup de choses aux politiques en
tout cas ceux qui ont le pouvoir mais je
pense que tous les jours ils ont à gérer
enfin et n'importe qui dans sa vie voit
à quel point c'est compliqué même de
mener c'est de l'avis de son foyer vous
imaginez un pays donc on reproche alors
il n'a pas tenu sa promesse et tout ça
alors que c'est une suite illimité de
compromis de processus d' équilibre je
suis surpris à quel point les gens
jugent tout ça sans savoir le jeu du
président c'est donc au théâtre du chêne
noir à partir du 9 décembre
auteur julien gélase dans une mise en
scène de gérard gélas remercie tous les
trois présents participer à cette
émission merci de nous avoir suivis et
rendez vous au prochain numéro
[Musique]